it's a countdown to tonight's Vanderpump
reunion finale they've strung us along
teasing a shocking Scandal bombshell
which left producers heads spinning just
watched part three of this reunion okay
and let me just tell you you thought I
should go
boyfriend if you were thinking that you
were like over it or you're ready to
forgive anyone I swear
you're gonna get shot right back to
square one apparently there is something
so wild so wild that's gonna be revealed
in the reunion that could potentially
have you guys not want to sign back up
to be on the show The chakra is revealed
in the last five minutes of the Bravo
reunion in fact production had to pick
cameras back up for a second time a few
days after the reunion shot in March
among the fan theories Raquel's pregnant
I I don't think so Affair started during
James and Raquel era maybe yeah many
think the big reveal is that this has
been going on for more than two years so
if you think about it that would mean
the cover-up goes deep because remember
Sandoval helped put the 25 000 bill for
James to propose to Raquel in 2021 only
for them to break up six months later
there you go guys 750. 950 bucks one
thousand dollars three thousand okay we
got fire dancers we got a silk
performance